>> Jesse: NO SECRET THAT JOE HAS
BEEN PUSHING ELECTRIC CARS THE
WHOLE TIME HE HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE.
TELL US GREEN IS THE WAY TO NOT
REALLY WORRY ABOUT HIGH GAS
PRICES AND JOE HAS VEHICLES IN
MIND G.M.C. HUMMER ELECTRIC
PICKUP TRUCK.
ONE OF THESE BABIES WILL SET YOU
BACK AT LEAST 87 Gs BUT BUT,
HEY, ANYTHING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
JOE TOOK ONE OF THE PUPPIES OUT
FOR A SPIN LAST YEAR.
REMEMBER?
[TIRES SQUEALING]
>> JUMP IN THE BACK?
ON THE ROOF?
>> YOU LOOK GOOD, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> THIS SUCKER IS SOMETHING
ELSE.
MY CORVETTE THREE TIMES AS FAST.
THIS IS UP CREDIBLE.
>> Jesse: MAY BE FAST, JOE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS NOT FAST
AT?
FULLY CHARGING.
>> HUMMER IS THE QUICKEST
CHARGING VEHICLE ON THE MARKET
RIGHT NOW BUT WHAT IF YOU ARE
NOT AT A FAST CHARGER AND JUST
AT HOME.
HOW FAST DOES IT CHARGE?
>> LEVEL ONE CHARGING 120-VOLT
USING THE HUMMER CABLE RIGHT NOW
IT'S ABOUT 6:00 P.M. ON TUESDAY
AND IT SAYS IT WILL BE FULL BY
SATURDAY AT 10:55 WHICH IS FOUR
PLUS DAYS OF CHARGING, WOW.
>> BUT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO WAIT
FOUR DAYS TO CHARGE YOUR TRUCK,
YOU CAN ALSO BUY SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT.
A 240-VOLT LEVEL 2 CHARGER
THAT'S GOING TO SET YOU BACK 500
BUCKS PLUS AROUND 1,000 JUST TO
INSTALL IT.
EVEN THEN THE CHARGING IS NOT SO
FAST.
>> THE JUICE BOX LEVEL 2
CHARGER, 240 VOLTS AT MY GARAGE.
NOW IT SAYS IT WILL BE DONE
TOMORROW BY 6:30 SO ABOUT 24
HOURS OF CHARGING FROM 4% TO 10.
>> Jesse: DAD, CAN WE GO
SOMEWHERE?
I'M SORRY, GIVE ME 24 HOURS.
BUT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO WAIT
THAT LONG, CAN YOU CHARGE IT AT
A FASTER LEVEL WITH A LEVEL 3
SUPER CHARGER ISN'T NORMALLY
USED IN HOMES BECAUSE IT'S
$35,000.
SO ASIDE FROM CHARGING ABOUT AS
FAST AS A TURTLE, THERE IS OTHER
THINGS JOE DIDN'T SEEM TO THINK
ABOUT IN HIS HUMMER FANTASY.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A FAMILY
HAD ONE OF THESE ELECTRIC CARS
IN FLORIDA WHEN THE POWER WENT
OUT?
BECAUSE OF THE HURRICANE AND YOU
HAVE TO FLEE?
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU COULD STOCK UP
ON GAS.
NOT TO MENTION GOING GREEN MEANS
MORE INFLATION.
THESE BATTERIES, SOLAR AND
WINDOW REQUIRE MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF ENERGY.
LIKE NEARLY 2,000% MORE NICKEL
THAN FOSSIL FUELS USED FOR THE
SAME AMOUNT OF ENERGY, MORE
LITHIUM, GRAPHITE, STEEL.
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE OUR EYE
LINES ON MAKE ALL THESE EVs
EVs AND ELECTRICAL GRID IS
OVERWHELMED IT.
HAPPENED ALREADY IN.
25.
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BAN ALL
GAS POWERED CARS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY BANNED GAS
LAWN MOWERS.
LESS THAN A WEEK AFTER THEY
ANNOUNCED THAT CALIFORNIA HAD TO
ASK ITS CITIZENS NOT TO CHARGE
THEIR EVs BECAUSE LITT